for being with us for the news here at
noon on a friday i'm alex backus we do
begin with breaking news right now we're
following from sunset park investigators
they're on scene right now after a brush
fire started a short time ago
hector mejia live on scene near sunset
and mcleod with details hi hector what
can you tell us
hey there alex right behind me we have
the scorched patch of earth but first i
want to show you the clark county
firefighters that just
finished wrapping up their hoses after
putting out a large fire here
this is as you just mentioned at sunset
park we have this wide stretch of
brush fire that was just put out not too
long ago now the park
is open the fire is out as you can see
but this report of the fire was right
next to the police substation just
east of it and you know sunset park is
pretty large just for some perspective
this area is right when you come in
southbound from the sunset and mcleod
entrance
we also have dramatic video that shows
part of sunset
park while it was on fire earlier this
morning
i mean just imagine coming down for a
jog and running into this
this video from ruby morales shows the
flames shooting from the ground in the
large plume of dark smoke a lot of
people saw across the valley
the fire department got word around 10
o'clock this morning the good news
this afternoon no reports of injuries
and no structures were threatened again
back out here live you can see this wide
stretch of earth here just
scorched after a report of a brush fire
out here again
it's out but in terms of what started
that fire in the first place
investigators still don't know but that
is something they'll be looking into
reporting live from sunset park hector
mejia 8 news now